the former british ambassador to
rochester andrew wood hello to andrew
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning what will the russian
people be hearing about what's happening
in ukraine do you think
i think a large proportion of the
russian people will suspect that it's
true
that all sorts of emotional forces will
be
making them very very anxious
to deny it
they had great trust in the armed forces
greater trust in them than the
government in general
and
this is such a terrible shock for them
too i
believe
the u.n security council is meeting
russia wants it to meet in emergency
session probably around about three
o'clock this afternoon what do you think
that russia will say to the u.n security
council
well i think you know as well as i do
that would be vigorous deniers it's not
them they never did anything like that
they never would it must be the
ukrainians or if not the ukrainians
possibly the americans or
anything
i think in slight defense of the the
russians one has to remember that this
is
a a war in which
a lot of civilians are taking part
um it's also a war which in the area of
which the
russians have been losing
um
some of them are probably rather
frightened
and their reactions are accordingly
wicked
but
emotionally perhaps understandable
we know that the ukrainian president is
hoping to speak to the u.n security
council later on today but we're also
being told that potentially there could
be face-to-face talks between him and
president putin
from your experience do you think that
will could happen and if so what could
be hoped for expected from that
i don't think it will happen and i
wouldn't trust putin
a single word that he would utter in
that case
the trouble is that the war has not
reached a position where it is decisive
it has been a shock for the russians
to
reveal themselves as being so inept
militarily
and the fierceness of the ukrainian um
[Music]
resolution
it's also a complete contrast to what
they not only expected but relied on
it wasn't just the speed of their
victory they suppose
but also that it would be possible
thereafter for them in effect to rule
ukraine
which it evidently now is not
this war is going to go on
until when
until russia loses or ukraine loses
there is no
point where you think
russia will um
strategically
withdraw the whole of ukraine
uh i think that's that's unlikely
it should happen
with the interests of the russian people
but it did happen
this even if uh putin won and dominated
the entire country or the eastern part
of it or whatever it is
he would not
now
be able to secure the support
of ukrainian people
whom he's described as the same people
as the russian people
this is this is absolutely
unforgivable
but people do not forget such things
you of course um
having been an ambassador um for the
court of saint james in
in russia know about russian politics
very well
um which countries do you think
that the president president putin can
still rely on it does look as though you
know china is very much sitting on the
fence india pakistan brazil
how much will he continue to rely on
those countries do you think
well i think he will rely on a degree of
difference between other countries which
are
opposed to him it i think we are also in
a difficult position in that we
the west in general and nato in
particular would like a peaceful outcome
of course
but we can't negotiate on behalf of the
ukrainians
it's up to them to decide what is
possible and what should be achieved in
any negotiations
the uh
zelensky has
said already that
they will make no territorial
concessions
or at least not immediately
but um
one just doesn't know i think it does
depend now on what happens in the
eastern half of
of ukraine
to what degree the
russians are going to
try to create a
land continuity between
don bass and
crimea and eventually odessa
so that there's a there's a lot to
to wonder about
but not that much you can actually make
a prediction for
i think the russians are an impossible
position
and i believe that
far more russia
sympathizes with the ukrainians than is
admitted in uh reflection of the public
polls
okay we know that the eastern region is
is where russian troops are focusing uh
the firepower at the moment but we also
know that president butin um
congratulated the um hungarian leader
who was re-elected
yesterday how much concern might there
be about what could happen from the west
well i think there is there are
questions as to how uh continue the
cohesion
in the west will
um be maintained
hungary is a particular uh example of
something not
in line with the rest of the eu
but it's obvious that there's far more
concern and i think understanding in the
eastern parts of the eu than there is in
the central
central parts
um
i think we all have a dilemma we would
like this to stop
but we would like it to stop in such a
way that it is not renewed
and the idea that for example there
should be some agreement
that uh the russians would have control
over
donbass and uh um crimea
would just be a means of providing
a way in which the whole thing will be
renewed at a later date
i don't think that the russians will
want to carry on fighting for it forever
but nor do they want
a a
piece which deprives them of what
they've already got
um
putin himself is in a
rather central position yes but also a
rather isolated position
in that he doesn't have any machines
which provided him with
adequate discussion
with his military or other people
about what the
possibilities may be
and he's also in a position where he's
politically rather desperate you cannot
afford a defeat
so andrew um thank you very much indeed
for your expertise we always appreciate
you um joining us on the program so
thank you for taking the time this
tuesday morning